الاخبار اهلا بكم نفت هيئه الاركان العامه
الاوكرانيه سيطره الروسيه على مدينه
باكموت وقالت انها تتصدى للكثير من هجمات
ما وصفته بالعدو وكان رئيس شركه فاجنر قال
ان مقاتلي رفعوا العلم الروسي ورايه قواته
على المبنى الاداري في مركز
وكان الرئيس الاوكراني قال ان الوضع في
باخموت كان ساخنا جدا بشكل خاص امس الاحد
قال المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي انه تم
استدعاء مروحيات ومقاتلات حربيه في عقاب
رصد مسيره مجهوله تسللت من الاراضي
السوريه الى داخل الاجواء الاسرائيليه
واضاف انه تم اسقاط المسيره في منطقه
مفتوحه دون ان تشكل اي خطر بدورها قالت
هيئه البث الاسرائيلي ان المسيرات التي
دخلت من جهه سوريا يشتبه انها ايرانيه
نقلت وكاله الانباء السوريه سان عن مصدر
في شرطه دمشق ام انفجارا وقع في منطقه
المزه قرب العاصمه واضافت الوكاله ان
الانفجار كان لعبوه الناسفه بسياره مدنيه
ادى الى احتراقها دون وقوع اصابات وقد
استبعدت مصادر اسرائيليه ان تكون هناك
علاقه لتل ابيب بانفجار السياره
اعلن الحرس الثوري الايراني مقتل مستشار
عسكري اخر بعد اصابته بجروح في غاره
اسرائيليه على ضواحي العاصمه السوريه فجر
الجمعه وشدد الحرس على ان ما سماها جريمه
الكيان الصهيوني المجرم لن تمر دون رد
اعلنت الحكومه الاسرائيليه انشاء الحرس
الوطني في وزاره الامن القومي اضافت
الحكومه ان الحرس الوطني سيتعامل مع حالات
الطوارئ الوطنيه مثل الاضطرابات اثناء
عمليه حارس الاسوار
من جانبه قال زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه
يا ادلبي ان حكومه نتنياهو قلصت ميزانيات
الصحه والتعليم والامن لتمويل جيش من
البلطجيه وميليشيا خاصه لوزير الامن
القومي اتمار بن جفير
نقلت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه عن وزيره
النقل في حكومه نتنياهو قولها ان الحكومه
ستستانف العمل على مشروع التعديلات
القضائيه بعد عيد الاستقلال مباشره حسب
تعبيرها
افادت وكاله رويترز بارتفاع اسعار النفط
باكثر من سته في المئه وذلك بعد اعلان عدد
من الدول العربيه المنضويه تحت مظله اوبك
بلس الى جانب روسيا عن تخفيض طوعي في
انتاجها النفطي اعتبارا من شهر مايو ايار
القادم وحتى نهايه العام الجاري في خطوه
احترازيه تهدف الى دعم استقرار اسواق
النفط في المقابل قال المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي انه لا يعتقد ان
تخفيضات اوبك بلس منطقيه في هذا التوقيت
نظرا لعدم اليقين في السوق
ختام موجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]